j'aurais caca boudin akakro tort
qu'est-ce qui vous appelle micro il ya
d'autres choses qui vous disent mais
d'autres personnes vous avez déjà
entendu comme ça et puisque est ici plus
que j'ai dessiné toi tu a dessiné la
merde et la piscine péguilhan tous été
condamnés
la puce la bulle a pu la merde lumineux
du lait c'est pas mal dans les gros durs
un effort à tous tu te dis pour toi
pourquoi on l'aimé quand avait longtemps
fait faire des bêtises
alors tu te punit toi même pas du groupe
à qu'est ce que tu me dire tu dis merde
au secteur entendu ça c'est mon papa
parce que à chaque fois d'un vrai qu'il
est bien des gros mots sans blague alors
vas-y qu'est ce qu'il dit dans sa
voiture merde espèce de colas et c'était
être dix communes jamais kaunas moi je
n'ai jamais connu c'est quoi le commande
je ne pars
c'est les filles qui apprennent les
groupements garçons épaisse et les
garçons et toi ou tu les as appris
quelques ombres qui tend à vente mère et
un plus gros mots encore plus gros
hopper gros pépère gros pépère fois lui
est encore plus gros que les vertes
vallées et aime bien dire des mots notre
nom pourquoi parce que je pense que
c'est mal pour lui
qui te dit que c'était mal poli mois il
pâtit aussi de la gare
[Musique]